[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهداء في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من واشنطن من حديث يفتحوا الباب
لتزويد اوكرانيا
وفي برلين اعلن عن قرار المانيا فعلا تقيم
دبابات من طراز ليفرد لاوكرانيا القرار
ياتي بعد حالته من التردد والسجال بين
حلفاء اكياز الغربيين
وهذه صور تاتينا من عمان التي زارها
بنيامين نتنياهو في اول تحرك خارجي له منذ
عودته الى رئاسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجانب الاردني ركز على ضروره الالتزام
بالوضع القائم في القدس
في مواضيع الحصاد
في تحول في موقف واشنطن مسؤولون امريكي
يكشف للجزيره ان البيت الابيض سيزود
اوكرانيا بدبابات ابرامز وان القرار سيعلن
والاربعاء المانيا تحسم ترددها والمستشار
اولف جولد يوافق على تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات لبرج الكريم لن يقولوا ان الخطوه
ستترك اثرا لا يمحى على العلاقات بين
موسكو وبرلين
موجه اقالات واستقالات غير مسبوقه في
اوكرانيا على خلفيه ملفات فساد والاجراءات
تشمل نائب رئيس مكتب زنسكي ونائب وزير
الدفاع ونائبه وزير البناء التحتيه وفي
اكمل تغيير لمسؤولين ميدانيين في وقت
الحرب عزل حكام مقاطعه اكياس وستروجيا
وسومي وخرسون واديني بروفيتو بالتزامن مع
احتدام المعارك شرقا
تركيا تعلن تاجيل المفاوضات الثلاثيه مع
السويد وفيرلندا للانضمام للنيتو دون
تحديد موعد رئيس وزراء السويد يقول ان
بلاده تريد استئناف الحوار مع تركيا بشان
الانضمام الى الاطلسي وفنلندا تستبعد حسم
القضيه قبل الانتخابات التركيه وتلمح
الامكانيه المضيء بشكل منفرد في سعيها
لدخول الحلف
[موسيقى]
في اول زياره خارجيه له بعد عودته لرئاسه
الوزراء لتنياهو يلتقي الملك عبد الله في
عمان العاهل الاردني يشد على ضروره احترام
الوضع القائمه في الحرم القدسي والتزام
التهدئه والصحافه الاسرائيليه تنقل تعهد
لتنياهو بالحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي
والقانوني للمسجد الاقصى
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تحديد القاضي طارق البيطار
مطلع شهر فبراير موعدا للاستماع لاربعه
عشر شخصا مدعا عليهم في قضيه انفجار مرفا
بيروت منهم رئيس الحكومه السابق حسن دياب
ومديره الامن العام عباس ابراهيم وامن
الدوله توني صليبه لكن النائب العام لدى
محكمه التمييز عاد اليوم وقال ان يد
المحقق طارق البيطار مكفوفه عن هذا الملف
بحكم القانون لانه لن يصدر حتى الان اي
قرار قضائيين في دعوى مرفوعه رايكم بشان
هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في
نظركم ما نقالات استئناف التحقيق في
انفجار مرفا بيروت
25% قال انه يمكن تحريك القضيه مجددا
وتوقع اربعه 34% عوده التحقيق الى التجميل
في حين توقع 41% دخوله اطراف سياسيه على
الخط
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصه الرقميه تجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا اكثر من مليون
طفل في العراق خارج فصول الدراسه اليونسكو
تقول ان الرقم يشكل تحديا كبيرا لتطوير
واقع التعليم في البلاد
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤول امريكي للجزيره ان البيت الابيض
حسن قراره بتسديد اوكرانيا بدبابات ابرامز
وان الاعلان الرسميه قد ياتي غدا الاربعاء
ونقلت وكالته عن مسؤولين امريكيين من
العمل سيتواصل على صفقه دبابات امر رمز
لاوكرانيا وسيتم شرائها ضمن مساعدات امنيه
قادمه واضاف المسؤولون ان الاعلان
الامريكي عن صفقه دبابات ام رمزي سيكون
بالتزامن مع اعلان المانيا بشان دبابات
وبينما حذرت موسكو من طبيعات لا تمحى
للخطبه على العلاقه مع برلين اكدت وكاله
الانباء الالمانيه ان المستشاره الالماني
اولاف شولدز وافق على تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات وكانت صحيفه ديرشبيل قد نقلت عن
مصادر قولها ان المانيا ستسمح كذلك لبلدان
اخرى مثل بولندا باعاده تصدير دبابه ليبرت
الى اوكرانيا
وكان وزير الدفاع الالماني قد قال لنا
بامكان الدول التي تمتلك دبابات لبرد
الالمانيه ان تزود اوكرانيا بها ولن تعترض
المانيا على ذلك
دينا عته ضعف تعبانه
مركزيه المانيا في الطليعه عندما يتعلق
الامر بدعم اوكرانيا اطلقت المانيا الان
حزمه من الدبابات وانظمه باتريوت هذا يعني
ان المانيا انفقت اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات
يورو اجمالا بالاضافه الى جميع الالتزامات
الانسانيه وخدمات الدعم الاخرى
الى كاز اهميتها ومميزاتها في العرض
التاليه
تعد دبابات ريبورد 2 الالمانيه الموجوده
في نحو 20 دوله من افضل المجنزرات في
الغرب وقد دخلت الخدمه منذ عام 79 تعتبر
من دبابات القتال الرئيسيه وتبلغ سرعتها
القصوى نحو 70 كم في الساعه تزن الدبابه
الواحده اكثر من 60 طنا وهي مزوده بمدفع
من عيار 120 مليمترا ويمكنها اصابته
الاهداف على مسافه تصل الى خمسه كيلومترات
اضافه الى انها مزوده بمدفع مضاد للطائره
وتوصف بانها المزيج المثالي من الحمايه
والتنقل والقدره على المناوره والقوه
ناريه كما انها مزوده بقوادفه لقنابل
الدخان
ينضم الينا من برلين مراسل الجزيره عيسى
طيبه ومن البنتاجون مراسل الجزيره فادي
منصور عيسى اذا هو ترخيص
وموافقه صحيح
نعم هو ترخيص وموافقه من المستشار او
بالاحرى ايضا بعد موافقه المجلس الفجرالي
الامن ويضم الوزارات السياديه فضلا عن
المفتش العام للجيش الالماني او بما يسمى
اركان هذا القرار للمنتخب من طرف
المستشاريه ايضا كما ذكرت همم ديرشبيل عن
مصاديرها المقربه من الحكومه الالمانيه
بان هذه النوع من الدبابات الذي سيتوجه
مباشره الى اوكرانيا هو من مخزونات الجيش
الالماني فضلا عن خطه متوسطه وطويله المدى
عن مخزونات الاخرى من الصناعه ويقصد بها
الدبابات التي لم تستخدم بعد
ويعتقد بان عددها نحو 200 دبابه ام
بالدبابات التي بحوزه الجيش الالماني
فيعتقد بان عددها نحو 350 دبابه اما شركه
ريلمي تال المصنعه فهي بدورها قادره على
تربيه نحو ان 130 دبابه على الاقل 20 منها
خلال شهر ابريل القادم في المحصله هذه
الدبابات او هذه الموافقه الالمانيه
لتتضمن جزئيه ثاني رئيسيه الجزئيه الاولى
هي الترخيص الامن المباشر بحيث يمكن
لبرلين ان ترسل هذه الدبابات مباشره
والترخيص الثاني وهو الموافقه للطرف
الثالث بحيث ان كل الدول التي تمتلك هذا
النوع من الدبابات بامكانها ان تزود
اوكرانيا بها ويعتقد بان عددها نحو 20
دوله الامر للاخر الذي قالت المصادر
المقربه من الحكومه الالمانيه هذا المساء
بان بان الدبابات الموجهه والتي تم
الموافقه عليها هي الدبابات من جيل اه سته
بحيث ان الجيش الالماني يمتلك دبابات تبدا
من الجيل اي اثنين الى الايه سبعه وهي
بمعنى اخر دبابه متطوره وحديثه وهي ايضا
جزء لا يتجزء من سوناتا الجيش الالماني
لانه يستخدمها تعتبر واحدا من روافد القوه
المسلحه الناريه الالمانيه فدي وانت في
البنك سابقا لم يكن متحمس لارسال دبابات
ابرامز الى اوكرانيا همم قال وقتها بانها
دبابات معقده كيف نفهم التحول بالموقف
الامريكي
والتزامن مع اعلان المانيا ارسال ريبورد
ايضا
نعم امانه طراحه هذا السؤال تحديدا على
مسؤول امريكي طلب عدم ذكر اسمه يتمكن
بمناقشه قضايا حساسه لم يتم الاعلان رسميا
عنها قال ان الرئيس هو الذي سوف يعلن يوم
الاربعاء وفق حديثه عن قرار الاداره
الامريكيه تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات اشار
الى ان هذه الدبابات لن تخرج من مخزون بل
سيتم شراؤها من الشركات والتعاقب بشانه
وبالتالي هذا الامر سوف يستغرق شهرا
النقطه الثالثه التي اشار اليها وفق
تقديره بان الولايات المتحده سوف تزود
اوكرانيا بنحو 30 الى 50 دبابه
تقديراته التي لديها سالته تحديدا عن
المساله التحول في موقف الاداره الامريكيه
اشار الى ان هذا التغير ليس همم نتيجه
اسباب عسكريه بما ان البابونج كان يعتبر
ان دبابات ابرامز لن تخدم الحاجات الملحه
الانمي للقوات الاوكرانيه لانها تمثل تحدي
كبير على مستوى استخدامها اجهزها المعقده
لكن بالاضافه الى ذلك تحديدا الجانب
اللوجستي وايضا الاستهلاك الكبير للوقود
وبالتالي وفق تقديرها ان هذا الامر مدفوع
بحسابات سياسيه على راسها اولا عمليا دفع
المانيا للموافقه اولا على تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات من طراز همم من مخزونها لدى
قواتها والثانيه من قبل الدول التي
تمتلكها خصوصا ان المانيا عندما تزود هذه
الدول بدبابات في سياق توقيع عقود التوريد
ينبغي لهذه الدول قبل ان تستخدم هذه
الدبابات او نقلها الى طرف ثالث تحديدا ان
تحصل على موافقه المانيه وبالتالي وفق هذا
المسؤول الامريكي الذي تحدثنا اليه السبب
هو سياسي يتعلق تحديدا بتسهيل هذا القرار
امام المانيا في ظل الوضع السياسي القام
في المانيا لكن ايضا لدواعي ايضا سياسيه
داخليه بحكم ان بعض الاصوات بدات تتعالى
هنا سواء في الكونجرس وتحديدا بطبيعه
الحال في العاصمه واشنطن بضروره التامين
كل ما تطلبه همم اوكرانيا من اجل ان تتمكن
من صد اي عمليات عسكريه روسيه واسعه وايضا
لكي تشتاق تتمكن من شان هجوم مضاد مع
نهايه فصل الشتاء جلال شكرا لكما فادي
منصور في البنتاجون وعيسى طيب في برلين
من برلين الكسندر مولر عضو لجنه الدفاع في
البرلمان الالماني السيد الاكسدر ما
الحسابات السياسيه
لالمانيا وامريكا وتزامن الاعلان عن ارسال
دبابات ابرامز ولبرت الى اوكرانيا
انا درويش
الاعلانات لكن في المانيا كانت هناك
مناقشات استمرت منذ اشهر وفي الاونه
الاخيره ازدادت حده لان
كانت هناك حاجه
الدبابات لكن المستشارنا تعرض للضغوط حتى
اتخذ قراره بعد التردد ممكن ان نفهم اكثر
سياق هذا التحول في الموقف الالماني هل
كان مرتبط
بموافقه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
ارسال دبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا لتقدم
بالتالي المانيا على على هذا الفعل ارسال
دبابات
لا نعلمه السبب لماذا قرر
المستشفى كانت تردد المستشار شولدر هناك
شائعات بانه كان يربط قرار بالموافقه
بموافقه الولايات المتحده على ارسال
الدبابات الامريكيه كانت هذه شائعات
حكوماتنا نفت ان يكون هناك ترابط لكن من
يدري نحن نعلم ان الشمس لا يريد ان يتصرف
بمفرده
بعزله عن الاخرين لماذا هذا ربما هذا هو
السبب الان قررت جميع ارسال الدبابات
بطريقه اخرى هل هناك سياق ميداني في
اوكرانيا يجعل المانيا همم
ترغب بارسال الدبابات الان لانها كانت
متردده في السابق هل هناك سياق ميداني في
الحرب ترى المانيا بضروره ارسال د الان في
هذه المرحله
من الناحيه الرسميه لا نسمع مثل هذا السبب
لكن هذا ممكن تماما نعلم ان الاوكرانيين
يتعرضون للضغوط والروس يزدادون قوته وهم
يهاجرون
وحصلوا على مدينه سولدار والان يظن ذاهبون
الى ضخمه وكل خطوط الدفاع الاوكرانيه
تعاني من ضعف ربما هذا الوضع هو الذي حث
اتخاذ القرار في اوروبا بهذا الاتجاه
مصادر امريكيه سيتم التعاقد بشان هذه
الدبابات
وستغرق عده اشهر
للتدريب وبالتالي ان تدخل الخدمه في الحرب
مع القوات الاوكرانيه لهذا يعني بالضروره
بان دبابات لبرد الالمانيه ستدخل الى
اوكرانيا قبل ابرامز
ايضا
اعتقد ذلك بالضروره اعتقد ان دبابه اللفظ
اثنان تحتاج الى تدريب مكثف فهي ليست
بسيطه من الناحيه الميكانيكيه تحتاج الى
الكثير من التدريب والتعلم عليها من جانبه
الجنود الاوكراني نعلم ان الجنود
الاوكرانيين
يتعلمون بسرعه لكننا قد يحتاجون الى
اسابيع لكي يجيد استخدامها هذه الدبابات
والامر ينطبق على دبابات ابرامز لا يمكن
نتوقع من استخدامها بعد اسبوع مثلا طبعا
موسكو كانت شديده اللهجه بما يتعلق بتزويد
المانيا دبابات للقوات الاوكرانيه كيف
تتوقعون الانعكاسات المحتمله لهذا القرار
الالماني
كل الصراحه انا لا اتوقع ان يتغيرا في
العلاقه نحن لدينا علاقه طويله مع روسيا
والعلاقات لك منذ بدل الحرب تقريبا شبه
انقطع التواصل بشانها
وعن لا يوجد ذلك التواصل
وبين 2000 والاخرى يتم تبادل افكار او سير
لكن لا احد يريده تغيير الموقف اذا يمكن
ان نقول ان علاقه غير قائمه فعليا
وروسيا لم تتعرض لبلدان لانها لا تمتلك
القوه ولا تريد حربا اخرى
نتوقعوا كلمات قويه شديده اللهجه لكن هذا
عن ذلك لا اتوقع اي شيء شكرا
الالماني نشرك معنا في النقاش من موس سفير
اوندريل بكلانوف نائب رئيس جمعيه
الدبلوماسيين الروس السفير بكلانوف سمعت
همم ضيفنا الكسندر مرر يقول بان روسيا لن
ترد على هذا القرار الالماني والامريكي
بتزويد القوات الاوكرانيه
بدبابات ليبرد وابرز ما رايك
[موسيقى]
له نهايه و سوف نعلمهم الدرس كما علمنا
علمناهم سابقا عندما استخدموا الدبابات
الالمانيه لقتل الروس ان الدوله الالمانيه
دوله مجرمه قتلت 27 مليون مواطن روسي ولم
نسمح لهم بقتل الروسيين بعد هذا كنا نعتقد
ان الدرس التاريخي الذي قدمناه لهم عندما
انتصرنا على الفاشيه وانقدنا اوروبا كنا
نعتقد ان هذا الدرس
كذلك سوف نضطر ان نقوم بتعليمه درسا جديدا
ولكن هذا سيكون الدرس الاخير واذا بدات
الحرب النوويه فان المانيا التي
الدوله الروسيه تهديدا قاتل سوف تختفي عن
الوجود
ولن نرحم من يقتل الروس ولم يكن لديهم اي
امل سوف نستخدم كل القوه الموجوده لدينا
نحن اكبر دوله نوويه في العالم وسوف نقف
اللي الدفاع عن انفسنا ولا نرحم من يقتل
الشعب الروسي سوف نعلمهم درس جديد
روسيا واوكرانيا والباحث في مؤسسه راند
للدراسات السفير ويليام همم ما الابعاد
السياسيه
لاعلان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات ابرامز دون ان ننسى طبعا
هذا التزامن مع المانيا الحليف للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بتزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات طبعا
بنيته
كانت وما زالت متوحده في مواقفها منذ بدء
هذه الحرب قضيه تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
كانت معقده نوعا وخاصه بالنسبه لالمانيا
لكن تم اتخاذ القرار
لاعاده تعزيز وحده الصف وتقويه
الصفر للوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا وهي تسعى
لاستعاده جميع اراضيها
السفير بكلانوف قلت قبل قليل بان روسيا
ستلقن المانيا درسا بحسب تعبيرك هل سيغير
هذا القرار الالماني الامريكي من
استراتيجيه روسيا في حربها على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه يعني هل ستع ربما روسيا بحسم
المساله قبيله وصول الدبابات الى القوات
الاوكرانيه مثلا
سنقوم ابراج سنه
اوكرانيا
المانيا ونحن متاكدين تماما انه لو بدات
حرب حقيقيه في اوروبا لن تستطيع امريكا ان
تنقذ المانيا حتى لا همم تحصل
نووي من الدول
هي منظمه حلف ليس
حقيقيات الحقيقيه
[موسيقى]
نكرر هذا الدرب من جديد ولا ننصح المانيا
ان يمدح من جديد مع روسيا
قوموا بكل اجراءات حتى لا تقوم دباباتكم
بقتل شعب الروسي والا والا سوف تتضرر
دولتكم بشده
يقول بان امريكا لن تستطيع ان تنقذ
اوكرانيا الحديث هنا بالمناسبه بحسب
المصادر عن من 30 الى 50 دبابه ابرمز الى
شهور طويله همم حتى يتم انتاج هذه
الدبابات والتدريب عليها خارج الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ومن ثم ادخالها الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بقياده القوات الاوكرانيه
بطبيعه الحال همم ما الحاجه الميدانيه
بوجهه نظر امريكا لادخال ابرامز في هذه
المرحله
فيسبوك
[موسيقى]
القوات الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
عمليات
العمليات المشتركه بين الصفوف المختلفه
المختلفه مهمه هذا يعني استخدام الدبابات
والمدفعيه
والطيران ان تعمل سويه
لتنفيذ الهجمات
المشتركه والدبابات مهمه في هذا السياق
هذا التزامن
والاتفاق الالماني الامريكي الالماني
الامريكي لتزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات في
هذه المرحله
ولايه
الاوروبي انهم لا يستطيعون ان يفهموا ان
الامريكيين
يقومون باستفعال الحرب
[موسيقى]
الاوروبيه
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه ان المنطقه
المانيا
كيف يقوم اشخاص ناضجون بافعال لا يدركونا
خطورته انها خطر وهذه تهديدات الاراضي
الاوروبيه اعتقد ان السياسيون الاوروبيين
هم اطفال ومستواهم التعليم لا يتناسب مع
مستوى الدول التي يقودها نحن نقف ضد
الموقف الاوروبي ونعتقد ان هذه سياسه خطره
للدول الاوروبيه ذاتها السفير وليا
بتقديرك ملا الانعكاسات المحتوله سواء
المحتمله عفوا سواء على الساحه الميدانيه
في اوكرانيا او على الساحه السياسيه ما
بين روسيا المانيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
لوكيشن
ستتركز في ميدان المعركه
اوكرانيا لديها ميزه الان وهي تتميز بجوده
الاسلحه التي تمتلكها لهذا السبب طلب من
المانيا الاستمرار في تزويدي اوكرانيا
بالسلاح المتطور لتمكين اوكرانيا من
استعاده الاراضي التي تحتلها
روسيا طبعا تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
وبقدرات دفاع جوي اكثر تطورا
وبدفعيه اكثر تطورا
ومدفعيه صاروخيه من طراز هايماس يبدو ان
كل ذلك يؤثر على ان الغرب كله عاقضا العزم
على دعم اوكرانيا لتحرير ارضها وانه
اوكرانيا مصممه على ذلك ايضا شكرا لكم
السفير وليام كورتني في واشنطن والسفير
اندريه في موسكو
تطورات وملف في تزويد اكياس بالدبابات
الغربيه تتزامن مع مشهد الميداني يقبل على
تغيير حاسم حيث تضغط دول غربيه على
اوكرانيا لتغيير سريع لتكتيكاتها وبعد
معركه استنزاف ضاريا شرقا الغرب يطالب كيف
بالالتفات جنوبا تحسبا لهجوم الروسي واسع
النطاق على جبهات متعدده
م على القتال الوحشي شرقا منذ اشهر
وتحديدا في بخموت رساله بعث بها المسؤولون
الامريكيون والغربيون لكيف فحوها دعوه
لاوكرانيا لتغير من تكتيكاتها الحربيه في
ساحه المعركه
تستبق قدوم فصل الربيع الذي يبدو وفق
حسابه الغرب موعدا لهجوم واسع محتمل
لعل هنالك ما يحفز لتغيير بوصله حسابات
كيف الاسلوب المختلف من القتال من شانه ان
يستفيد من زخم المعدات العسكريه الجديده
التي تصيرها تباعا من الولايات المتحده
ودول الاوروبيه واقر لقاء ورمشتاين الاخير
تعزيزها ففي الجبهه الشرقيه نقلت سينان عن
مسؤول استخباراتهم غربي كبير ان منذ ما
يقرب من سته اشهر كانت القوه الاوكرانيه
ترابح في معاركها مع الروس في بخموت على
طول 36 ميلا وقال انها معركه وحشيه واحده
حيث تتبادل كل طرف ما بين 100 متر من
الارض يوميا كما تبادل الالاف من قبائل في
المدفعيه يوميا تقريبا
التركيز على التخطيط لهجوم في الجنوب قد
يساعد كيف على تجنب معركه الاستنزاف
الدوريات هذه لكن الرئيس الاوكرانيه لا
يعتقد ان انتصار روسيا في بخموت امر واقع
فهي رمز مهم للمقاومه الاوكرانيه من وجهه
نظره يعني فوز روسيا فيها منحها فرصه
لتقدم اكثر الى المدن الشرقيه ذات اهميه
الاستراتيجيه في كل من سفيانس وكريموسك
واستعاده زمم المبادره في الحرب قد تدفع
بوتين وفق مسؤولين غربيين وامريين لتعبئه
اخرى للقوات تصل الى 200,000 رجل
قبل ايام قال مسؤول عسكري امريكي كبير ان
روسيا دفعت بعشره الاف من القوات البديله
سيئه التجهيز وغير المدرب على حد وصفه ولم
يغير ذلك من ديناميه القتال لكن اوكرانيه
تعاني ايضا من خسائر فادحه في المعركه
وتنفق كميه هائله من ذخيره المدفعيه يوميا
وهو اسلوب قتال لا تعتقد الولايات المتحده
انه مستدان لهذا تاتي الضغوط عليها لتغيير
تكتكاتها وتبدو النوايا اكثر وضوحا لشان
هجوم روسي او صعاب تعيين رئيس الاركان
العمل القوات المسلحه الروسيه
نقلا عن مسؤولين عربي
استهداف العاصمه في مره اخرى وفقهم
ويرشحون ان تواصل روسيا تركيز معظمه
اهتمامها على الاستر على المزيد من
الاراضي انطلاقا من بخموت وفي من منطقه
زبوجيا والحفاظ على البريد من منطقه
يوستوف الى شبه جزيره القرم بين خطط هجوم
الربيع الروسي المحتمل ودعوات غربيه
لاوكرانيه لتغيير تكتكاتها وخطتها
العسكريه تقترب الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا من طيعها الاول
[موسيقى]
وفي شان الاوكراني داخلي قدم مجموعه من
كبار المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
استقالاتهم بعد فضيحه فساد وعلنا
المسؤولون الاوكرانيون استقالاتهم بعد ان
كشفت وسائل الاعلام عن شراء امدادات للجيش
باسعار مبالغ فيها من ابرز المسؤولين
المستقلين نائب وزير الدفاع في الاسلام
شاب وفالف الذي كان مسؤولا عن الدعم
اللوجستيه للقوات المسلحه اضافه الى كريم
شينكو نائب رئيس مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
وايضا اوليكسي سيمونيكو نائب المدعي العام
ووصفت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه في بيان
لها تلك الاتهامات بانه لا اسس لها من
الصحه
وتاتي هذه الاستقالات على وقع موجه من
التعديلات الحكوميه في اوكرانيا على خلفيه
ملفات فساد اذ قالت الحكومه بالاقالت
الحكومه كذلك خمسه من حكام المناطق كما
صدق الرئيس بولو دي ميرسي على قرارات بمنع
عدد من المسؤولين المقالين من السفر وكان
رئيس مجلس الوزراء وقع في وقت سابق قرار
اقالته نائب وزير البنيه التحتيه غسيلي
لوزينسكي بناء على تحقيق الامن الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
لاحقا نرصده موجه الايقلات والاستقالات في
اوكرانيا بمزيد من التفاصيل ونسال ضيف
فقره المتابعه عن تداعيتها المحتمله
[موسيقى]
في موضوع اخر نقل التلفزيون التركي عما
سماها مصادر الدبلوماسيه تركيه ان
الاجتماع الخاص بالاليات الثلاثيه بين
تركيا والسويد وفنلندا المتعلق بمسيره
انضمام الاخيرتين الى حلف شمال الاطلسي قد
تم تاجيله يذكر ان الاجتماع الخاص بهذه
المفاوضات كان من المقرر عقده في بروكسل
في شهر فبراير شباط المقبل
رئيس الوزراء السويدي اولاذ كريسترسون
فاكد رغبه بلاده في العوده الى الحوار مع
تركيا بشان طلب انضمامها الى النيتو واضاف
في مؤتمر صحفي انه اذا لم يكن هناك حوار
فعال فسيكون صعبا على السويد ان تنضم
للنيتو وان هذا ستكون له تداعيات على
امنها مشيرا الى ان بلاده بحاجه الى عضويه
كامله
لكي تحظى بالضمانات الامنيه الوارده في
البند الخامس
بجانبه اشار وزير الخارجيه الفنلندي
بيكهافيستو الى ضروره ان تدرس هيلسنكي
احتمال الانضمام الى الناتو من دون السويد
واستبعد الوزير الفنلندي اي قرار من انقره
بشان الانضمام قبل الانتخابات التركيه
2022 تقدمت السويد وفنلندا بطلب الانضمام
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي لتتخلي بذلك هل سيكي
و ستوكهولم عن الحياه العسكريه التي
تلتزمان به منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
قد يتحولوا الى تاريخ المفصلي ان انتهى
وفقا ما تريدانه اثارت حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا مخاوفهما وهما من دول الجوار
الروسي
ترى السويد وفنلندا ان عضويتهما في النيتو
ستشكل ضمانه لهما في وجه اي تهديدات روسيه
مستقبلا
ولحلف الناتو سيزيد انضمام الدولتين من
توسعه الجيوسيا للدفاع عن دول البلطيق
التي يعتبرها الحلف بمثابه خاصرته الضعيفه
وسيصبح للحلف حدود اكثر قربا مع روسيا
ويتحول الى لاعب الرئيسي في الصراع معها
على النفوذ والموارد لكن الطموح قد يكون
ابعد منال على المدى المنصور في امتناع
تركيا يقف عائقا امام انضمام السويد
وفنلندا وتوسعه الناتو التي تحتاج الى
موافقه جميع اعضاء الحلف فانقر لن تقبل
الا بشروط تتعلق بانها القومي كما تقول
تسليم من تصنفهم تركيا ارهابيين كما تطالب
وجماعات
على لائحه الارهاب وعلى راسها حزب العمال
الكردستاني
في اللند من جهتها تقول انها اوفت بما
عليها فيما يتعلق بمطالب تركيا
وتؤكد السويد انها قامت بما يلزم هي
الاخرى وعلى انقر البدء بالتصديق على
عضويتها
وبين البحث عن توسيع دائره النفوذ ومن يرى
الامن القوميه اولويه لا تنازل عنها يبقى
مصير توسع الحلف من عدمه في دائره الترقب
على الاقل
[موسيقى]
ديوان الملكي الاردنيه ان الملك عبد الله
الثاني شدد خلال لقاء جمعه في عمان برئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو على
ضروره التزام بالتهدئه ووقف اعمال العنف
لفتح المجال امام افق سياسيا لعمليه
السلام كم شدد العاهل الاردني على ضروره
الحفاظ على الوضع القانوني والتاريخي
القائم في الحرم القدسي الشريف وعدم
المساسبه
ذكرى ديوانه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي في
بيان لقاء عمان ناقش القضايا الاقليميه
وتعزيز التعامل الاستراتيجي والامني
والاقتصادي بين اسرائيل والاردن بما يساهم
في استقرار
ما الذي جاء به دون سابق اعلان تمت زياره
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي لعمان ليس معروفه
ماذا سمع منه العاهل الاردنيه الذي جمعه
به لقاء النادر هو الاول منذ عوده بنيامين
نتنياهو الى السلطه في تل ابيب لكن ما
اسمعه الملك عبد الله الثاني لنتنياهو
ذكره بيان من الديوان الملكي قال البيان
ان العاهره الاردنيه
على موقف الاردن الثابت الداع الى
الالتزام بحل الدولتين بحيث يضمن قيام
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
ديوان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي لا يذكر
شيئا من ذلك وانما يشير الى مناقشه لقاء
عمان ما قال انها القضايا الاقليميه
وتعزيز التعاون الاستراتيجي والامني
والاقتصادي بين اسرائيل والاردن بما يساهم
في استقرار المنطقه
تحيدو عن ذلك وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
حين تقول ان نتنياهو تعاهد خلال لقائه
العاهره الاردنيه بالحفاظ على الوضع
التاريخي والقانوني للاقصى وذاك اقرب مكان
له المفاجاه جوا الى العاصمه الاردنيه في
اسرائيل التي تربطها معاهده سلام مع
المملكه الهاشميه تعترف بوصايتها على
المقدسات الاسلاميه في القدس
وتلك مقدسات باتت في دائره الخطر بمقدم
حكومه الاسرائيليه يحتل فيها رموز اليمين
المتطرف مواقع نافذه
استهل وزير الامن القومي المتطرف اثمار
كما نذكر فترته الوزاريه باقتحام باحات
الحرم القدسي
وتلاته محاولات تدليس مماثله من قبل
متطرفين يهود شجعتهم على ذلك تركيبه حكومه
لتنياهو الجديده
منذ تشكيله تلك الحكومه يزداد التوتر في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه على وقعتها الصعيد
الاحتلال تصعيد لا يبدا بالمداهمات
والاعتقالات في الضفه الغربيه ولا ينتهي
عند اشتعال ازمه اجلاء سكان تجمع الخان
الاحمر الى الشرق من مدينه القدس
للغايه ولم يتخلف عن ذلك مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي الذي زار منطقه تمهيدا
لزياره المقبله لوزير خارجيه في بلده
التحذير من تقويض حلل الدولتين تصدر
الجندل
تلك رساله اولي وارفعي شخصيه سياسيه
امريكيه تلتقي اقطاب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده الموصوفه بالاكثر تطرفا سياسيا
ودينيا
في الداخل ايضا
اضطرني قالت حلفه وزير الصحه والداخليه
اريا درعي بقرار من المحكمه العليا
ووسط خلافات سياسيه مع عدد من خلفائه لا
تفتح المظاهرات المناوله لسياسه حكومته
وزير الاعلام الاردني السابق سيد سميح حتى
الان لم نعرف ما الذي سمعه الملك عبد الله
من نتنياهو
هو مساء الخير لحضرتك كل المشاهدين الذي
سمعه الملك عبد الله هو ما ورد في بيان
الديوان الملكي وهو الذي جاء بريتلياه الى
عمان كما تعلم حضرتك الاردن من انتهاء
الانتخابات الكنيسه وقبائل تشكيل الحكومه
التنياهو المتطرفه العنصريه كان له تحرك
واضح لجلاله الملك باتجاه الاداره
الامريكيه وبتجاه الاوروبيين وايضا تحرك
عربي كان في اللقاء في القاهره القمه
الثلاثيه المصريه الفلسطينيه
ولقاء التشاوري في الامارات بحضور معظم
قائد الدول الخليج قبل قبل ايام كان في
جهد اردني بهذا الاتجاه هو كان في استعداد
ورساله اردنيه قيلت في مقابله الملك مع سي
ان ليله عطاء الثقه لحكومه بان الاردن
مستعد للعوده والمجابه السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل كما كان الحال في
فتره حكومه نتنياهو السابقه والجميع يذكر
ما كان في الفتره بين 2016 17 الى 2021
ورود وعلاقات سيئه بين الطرفين على خلفيه
العدوانيه الاسرائيليه تجاه القدس وتجاه
الفلسطينيين الذي جرى ان نتنياهو اليوم
بالتاكيد الطرف الامريكي وكما ورد قبل
قليل كان على الشاشه صحيح عواجر عن ناطق
الخارجيه الامريكيه يتحدث عن ترحيب امريكي
بخطوات تحفظ تدعم الوصايا الهاشميه
التي ترعاها يرعاها الاردن لانه وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه تتحدث عن اعلان
اسرائيلي بالحفاظ على الوضع القائم
هو الاردن يطالب الوضع القائم نتحدث عن
الوضع القائم ان المسجد الاقصى وحدوده
والاماكن والمسيحيه والاسلاميه تبقى كما
هي دون تقسيم دون اعتداء دون دون حفريات
دون موضوع تقسيم الزماني والمكان اللي هو
المنطق الاسرائيلي في التعامل الضمانات
الضغط واضح ان الاداره الامريكيه بالصوره
وهي وراء الموضوع زائد نتنياهو لديه
مشكلات لديه مشكله بالمعارضه التي تنظم
مظاهرات حاسده ضده لديها مشكله لديه مشكله
ايضا في في قدوم رمضان وانه لا يريد ان
يذهب الى استفزازات للفلسطينيين وربما كما
تذكر في رمضان السابق والذي قبله كان
تخوفات ايضا من الانتفاضه او اعمال مقاومه
شعبيه في في فلسطين ولديه ايضا يعني خليني
اقول ملاحقته بقضايا الفساد فيريد تهدئه
الاوضاع ولذلك جاء الى الاردن ليهادئ
الجبهه مع الاردن بتعهد بان لا ان تبقى
الامور بالمسجد الاقصى دون مس وان لا يتم
المس بالاماكن المقدسه هو الاردن ايضا
يضيف لانه حضرتك الخلافه الاردني
الاسرائيلي جوهريا على قضيتين القضيه
الاولى تتعلق بالاماكن المقدسه والوصايه
الهاشميه على الاماكن المقدسه الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه والامر الثاني اداره اسرائيل
ظهره لعمليه السلام مع الفلسطينيين وعدم
قيامه باي جهد سياسي مع الفلسطينيين
لاعطاء الفلسطينيين حقوقهم على راس الدوله
الفلسطينيه الجلاله الملك اليوم باللقاء
كانت تجديد على الامرين على اليوم في تعهد
اسرائيلي واضح انه الامريكان بالقصه وروما
مضغوطات ايضا من من اداره الامريكيه
وغيرها زائد الجهد الاردني الذي بدا بهذا
الموضوع لكن هذه اسرائيل يعني علينا ان
نتعامل همم
كيف يمكن هذا
مشكله اساسيه بان تلافه الحاكم قائم على
اساس نسف كل ما تفضلت به ونذكر ما فعله
اثمار في همم مستهل همم توليه المنصب
الوزاري وكيف يدفع يمين المتطرف الى
اتجاهات مغايره تماما عن ما تفضلت به الان
باقتضاب كيف يمكن
ضمان التزام اسرائيل بهذه التعاهدات اذا
كانت فعلا واقعيه
يعني هي تعهدات واقعيه وهذه المطالب وانا
بعتقد الولايات المتحده بالصوره زائد
الاردن ليس معنى بحل مشكله نتنياهو مع
حكومه مع تركيبته المتطرفه العنصريه
الموجوده هو المطلوب منه ان يجد حلول
لمعادله حكومه الداخليه بما يضمن همم ان
يذهب باتجاه تنفيذ هذا تعهد لكن احنا
الاردن او العرب او الفلسطينيين ليسوا
معنيين بايجاد ان الحل مشكله نتنياهو مع
ابن كثير مثلا هذه قصه وهذه مشكلته هو
عليه ان يجد الحلول في داخل حكومته وهو
رئيسه لقد تحرك من فلسطين وجاء الى الاردن
وتعهد بذلك في الالتزام هو الواجب لكن كما
قلت هذه اسرائيل ويتعامل بحذر الى همم في
في تنفيذ هذه ضمانات التي نعمل ان يتم
الالتزام بها لفتره طويله او من خلال
الفتره القادمه شكرا السيد سميح المعايطه
وزير الاعلام الاردنيه
في اليوم العالمي للتعليم قالت منظمه
يونسكو ان اكثر من مليونين طفل في العراق
بين سن السادسه والسابع عشر ليسالون خارج
فصول الدراسه واضافت المنظمه ان هذا الرقم
يشكل تحديا كبيرا لتطوير واقع التعليم في
العراق فضلا عن استمرار التداعي البنا
التحتيه المدرسيه ونقص المدارس ويصل عدد
الطلاب في الصف الواحد الى 200 في بعض
المناطق
في لبنان حدد القاضي طارق البيطار مطلع
شهر فبراير شروط القادم موعدا للاستماع
لاربعه عشر شخصا مبدعا عليهن في قضيه
انفجار مرفا بيروت لكن النائب العام لدى
محكمه التمييز في لبنان القاضي غسان
عويدات المشمول بموضوع الاستماع قال ان يد
طارق البيطار مكفوفه عن هذا الملف بحكم
القانون لانه حتى الان لم يصدر اي قرار
قضائيا في دعوى مرفوعات الضوء
مفاجاه المحقق العدلي اللبنانيه استئناف
التحقيق في فاجعه مرفا بيروت سرعان ما
تبعتها ارتديه انهج جمودا استمر اكثر من
عام بسبب تعليق عمله بدعوه السيسي التحقيق
لقد ضبط القاضي طارق البيطار قائمه
المطلوبين للتحقيق
واجال استجوابهم فبين السادس من فبراير
المقبل والثاني والعشرين منه سيتعين على
14 شخصا الحضور للاستجواب كل في موعده
المحدد
المدعى عليهم هم خليط من الساسه والقضاه
والعسكري من ابرزهم رئيس الحكومه السابق
حسن الذئاب وزير الداخليه الاسبق لهذا
المشنوق والمدير العام لامن الدوله اللواء
طوني صليبه والمدير العام للامن العام
اللواء عباس ابراهيم
ومدير المخابرات السابقه في الجيش العميد
كميل ظهر وقائد الجيش الاسبق جان قهوه دي
فضلا عن النائب العام التمييزي القاضي
غسان عويدات وقضاه اخرين غير ان قرارات
البيطار العائدي الى مهمتهم من طرف واحد
قبلت برفض فوري من بعض الجهات اذا اعتبر
النائب العام لدى محكمه التمييز ان المحقق
العدليه في قضيه المرفق يده مكفوفه عن هذا
الملف بحكم القانون ذلك ان البيطار لم
يصدر اي قرار بعد في الدعاوي المرفوعه ضده
تلك مما حكه قانونيه تبدو ردا على قول
البيطار في وقت سابق انه السند الى مطالعه
قانونيه تقضي بالا وجود لنص قانوني يجيز
كفى يده عن قضيه مماثله ويمكنه بالتالي ان
يدعي على اي شخص دون اذن من اي داره
اوزاره
[موسيقى]
اذا كما استفنا نعود الى قضيه الفساد في
اوكرانيا وسلسله الاستقالات والاقالات
المعلنه في ثياب والتي اعتبرت الاكبر منذ
بدا حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير الماضي فقط اعلن ممثل
الحكومه الاوكرانيه في البرلمان ان حكام
مناطق دينيترو
بتروجيت جنوب اوكرانيا وخرسون في الجنوب
وايضا سومي في الشمال والعاصمه كيف قد
غادروا مناصبهم اسباب اقاله هؤلاء
المسؤولين لم توضح بشكل رسمي لكن هناك
اشارات الى ان بعضهم
بالضلوعي في انتهاكات او اخطاء في الاشهر
الاخيره تقارير صحفيه كشفت ان
فالنتينو بتروجيست ونظرائه من مناطق سومي
وخرسونوجيا يخضعون لتحقيقات قضائيه وسائل
الاعلام عديده اتهمت بري وفي نوفمبر بمنحي
عقود الاصلاحي طرق بقيمه عشرات ملايين
اليورو لمجموعه شاركت في تاسيسها صديقتها
التي تعمل مدربه في مجال اللياقه البدنيه
وكان الرئيس الاوكراني
قد تحدث عن قرارات بشان موظفينا من مختلفه
المستويات في الوزارات ومراكز الحكومه
والمركزيه الاخرى بعدها بساعات اقيل نائب
وزير الدفاع
فولوف الذي كان مسؤولا عن الدعم اللوجستيه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في هذا السياق
افاد الموقع زد ان يو اي الاخباريه ان
وزاره الدفاع الاخرانيه وقعت عقدا لتزويد
الجيش بمواد غذائيه بنحو
324 مليون يورو وهو ما يفوق بضعين او
ثلاثه اسعار المنتجات الغذائيه الاساسيه
حاليا من ابرز الاسماء التي وردت في قائمه
الاقالات مساعد
مساعد مدير الاداره الرئاسيه تيريلو
تيموشينكو الذي ارتبط اسمه بفضائح قبل حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا وخلالها ايضا ففي
اكتوبر الماضي اتهم تيموشينكو باستخدام
سياره دفع رباعي منحتها مجموعه جنرال
موتورز الامريكيه لاوكرانيا لاغراض
انسانيه اسم اخر من قائمه المقالين هو
نائب المدعى العام اولكسي سيمونينكو الذي
اتهم بانه سافر مؤخرا الى اسبانيا في عطله
في حين يحضر على الرجال الاوكرانيين في سن
القتال السفر الى الخارج الا لاغراض مهنيه
على كل حال ينضم الينا
من ثياب السيد اولكسي هارون استاذ السياسه
المقارنه في جامعه اكياف مهيله سيد اولكسي
ما الظروف التي سمحت للفساد بان يتغلغل في
اداره الرئيس بولو دايلانسكي في هذه
المرحله
التغييرات الاشخاص نعم هذا صحيح لكن ليسوا
جميعا
ارتبطت اسمائهم بالفساد من بين القائمه
التي تعرضتموها هناك
نائبا
واحد معاونيه الرئيس
الاركان وهو ليس متهم
بالفساد ولكن سوء استخدام سياره اذا بشكل
عام يمكن ان نقول فان مكافحه الفساد
2014 مستمر وتم عمله الكثير لجعل النظام
اكثر شفافيه لكن بالطبع ما تزال هناك
قضايا فساد وحالات فساد في حاله الحرب ما
هو مهم ان نفهم هنا ان ليست هذه القضايا
التي ذكرتموها ليست كلها بل ربما قضيتان
فقط
لتخصصاني وكيل ال الوزاره والشعب
الاوكراني طبعا شعره بالغضب اذا هذه
القضيه
وايضا هناك حاله طوارئ في البلاد وهذا
يظهر ان مستوى الانتقاط موجود في اوكرانيا
رغبه سرياني احكام الطوارئ والاحكام
العرفيه في البلاد لذا انا ارى في هذا
المجتمع المدني
من هذه الاقالات لشركائها الغربيين في وقت
يتلقى مساعدات ماليه غير مسبوقه
دعوني اولا انه هي ما كنت اقول له الامر
الثاني ان رئيسكي استجابه بسرعه
وقال بعض الاشخاص وكذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي
قدر هذا التحرك اذا عندما نتحدث عن سوء
استخدام نحن لا نتحدث عن سوء استخدام
الاسلحه والمساعدات العسكريه هذه امور
شفافه اذا ربما ما حصل فعلا لم يتعلق بسوء
استخدام الاموال للمقدم من الغرب لكن بعض
الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالمنتجات المحليه الاوكرانيه مثل
المنتجات الزراعيه وغيرها التي تزوده بها
القوات المسلحه ماذا ذلك من المهم ان
النظر هنا ان هناك شفافيه
هناك حالات من الفساد فانها سيتم كشفها
والسلطات تقوم بمكافحتها نحن نعلم ان
الفساد امر صعب مكافحته لكن نحن نرى ان
هناك ردود فعل قويه من الشعب اساء سوء
استخدام الاموال من جانب بعض المسلمين
الدوله
منتصف الليل الا 90 ثانيه بمعنى ان
البشريه لم تكن يوما اقرب الى نهايه
العالم من اليوم وكشفت نشره علماء الذره
المشرفه على مشروع ساعه القيامه الرمزي
منذ عام 1947 التوقيت الجديد للساعه التي
تراقب انتهاء الازمنه لا الوقت وتقيس
بالتالي احتمالات حدوث كارثه عالميه وقد
تم اتخاذ القرار على خلفيه حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا والتهديدات البيولوجيه وانتشار
الاسلحه النوويه واستمرار ازمه المناخ
عملات التظليل التي ترعاها الدول
والتقنيات التخريبيه وتصف المنظمه المشرفه
على المشروع الساعه بانها تعبير مجازي عن
مدى قرب البشريه من التدمير الذاتي وتقول
ان عمليه اعاده الضبط السنويه يجب ان ينظر
اليها بصفتها دعوه للعمل لاعاده العقارب
الى الوراء الساعه الان
11:56 دقيقه بعد قليل منتصف الليل من
الجزيره كونوا على الموعد شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]